[Music]
this is drew been hair reporting live
from the discrete town medical clinic
the town is grappling with an outbreak
of hyper tingle osis a condition which
makes hair tangled and gnarled as you
can see the lion is out the door let's
go to dr. Sarah straight hair for the
latest doctor how is your clinic coping
with this horrifying outbreak please
everybody stay calm hyper tangle OSIS is
treatable and does not cause a long-term
health issues we treat it at our clinic
with a special conditioner which usually
cures the disease immediately it's not
always effective though we have limited
capacity and can only treat temptations
per day we're working to address these
issues thank you doctor good luck and
please keep us posted we go now to
Professor Joe Blitzstein from the
Harvard statistics department to tell us
more about how to make sense of this
disturbing situation professor can you
tell us how effective the treatment is
based on the limited data we have so far
we estimate that the treatment has a 60%
chance of success and a 40% chance of
failure let me get this straight so each
day you expect that six out of the ten
treated patients will be cured on
average 6 out of the 10 will be cured
but there could easily be more than 6 or
fewer than 6 on a particular day we have
to consider the whole distribution you
mean who distributes the treatment to
the clinic we should try to find out as
much as we can about the treatment but I
meant distribution in the statistics
sense when we're looking at a quantity
that can take on various possible values
the distribution tells us how likely any
particular value or range of values is
let's say we want to predict X the
number of patients who will be here
tomorrow the distribution of X specifies
the answers to questions like what's the
probability that X is 6 or what's the
probability that X is between 4 & 8 so
what is the distribution of X we don't
have enough data to be sure a lot is
unknown about this treatment for example
is it more effective on young people
than on older people assuming that each
patient has probably 0.6 of being
treated successfully and that these
patients are independent of each other
the distribution of X is called binomial
and kama 0.6 here's a picture of this
binomial distribution showing how likely
each possible value is hey that looks
just like my hair
you can see that six is the most likely
value but that doesn't mean it's
especially likely its probability is
about 0.25
there's about a 90% chance though that X
will be between 4 & 8
breaking news this system by modality
detected day 100 of our continuous
coverage is the hyper tangle Lucis
crisis has brought us a shocking
statistical development we go to
Professor Blitzstein for more a few
months ago I suggested the binomial
distribution as a plausible model for
how many patients will get cured on a
given day now with much more data it has
become clear that the binomial model is
inadequate how sup here's a histogram of
how many patients were cured in a day
compared with the binomial 10 comma
point 6 distribution as you can see they
look very different we have a case of by
modality there are two peaks in the
distribution I will be working closely
with dr. straight hair to figure out why
so is everything you told us about
binomials useless there are many
problems where the binomial fits well
this just isn't one of them even so the
binomial gives us benchmarks we can
compare the real data to and serves as a
building block for various more
complicated models please professor keep
us updated doctor Street hare and
professor Blitzstein have been working
tirelessly to unravel the mystery by
modality they're here now live to update
us on the results Joe and I have been
poring over the data and have found an
explanation we hope will not only
resolve the statistical anomaly but also
let us improve the percentage of
patients we can treat successfully the
conditioner comes from two different
suppliers normal distributors and Koshi
distributors we discovered that the
conditioner from normal distributors is
far more effective than the conditioner
from Koshi distributors on each day it
was completely random which supplier was
used on days when the conditioner came
from normal distributors the success
rate was 80% but for Koshi distributors
the success rate was only 40% the
overall distribution is a mixture of
binomials not a binomial here's the
histogram of the data compared with the
mixture distribution as you can see the
mixture fits much better than the
binomial did
we're back five a day a hundred and ten
of our coverage of the hyper tangle OSIS
crisis Koshi distributors stock price
has plummeted in the last week as it has
become clear but their quality control
is far inferior to their competitor in
other news normal distributors has just
released a new formula the conditioner
the patients can ply at home instead of
at a clinic with limited capacity
professor buh sign is here to help us
predict the ramifications hyper tangle
OSIS is rarer than you may think
possibly because the media have been
covering this 24 hours a day it would be
much better to obtain good data on how
many cases there are as a function of
time according to preliminary estimates
the probability of coming down with
hyper tangle OSes tomorrow for someone
whose hair is currently fine is only
point zero zero one the number of people
in discreet town with healthy hair is
currently about twenty thousand so we
can expect about twenty new cases
tomorrow but what is the distribution
I'm glad you asked
assuming the estimates I gave are
correct and that people come down with
hyper tangle OSes independently the
number of new cases is binomial twenty
thousand comma 0.001 that's pretty
unwieldy to work with since calculations
with that involve extremely large
numbers like twenty thousand factorial
which is about 10 to the 77339 omie 'l n
p distribution counts the number of
successes in n independent trials each
of which has probability P of success if
we have a binomial n P distribution
where P is small it turns out that we
can approximate it well with a beautiful
distribution known as the Poisson the
Poisson has one parameter usually called
lambda the probability of a Poisson of
lambda random variable equaling K is e
to the minus lambda lambda to the K over
K factorial for any non-negative integer
k for the problem at hand or should i
say at hair we can use the poisson of 20
as a good approximation to the binomial
20,000 comma 0.001 that looks very
pretty like a bell-shaped curve that's
another story but tell us professor how
many new cases do you predict will be
cured let's assume that the number of
new cases is Poisson of 20 and that they
all try the new treatment with success
probability 0.8 then the expected number
of new cases treated successfully is 0.8
times 20 which is 16 and the expected
number treated unsuccessfully is for the
distribution of the number of successes
is Poisson of 16 and the distribution of
the number of failures is Poisson of 4
surprisingly these two quantities are
independent with a Poisson number of new
cases knowing the number of successes
tells us nothing about the number of
failures Thank You professor for
explaining all of this to us any parting
words we need good data and good
statistical thinking in order to make
good predictions
you
you